and now alex is down to his last three
he's had a good career against the
tigers he has 25 home runs
brad keller's overall era is 2.77 but
at kauffman stadium and four starts
willie castro
who had a big night last night he had
three hits oh
good pitch salvi goes down to dozier and
brad keller has his first strikeout
miguel cabrera
and he got him with a fastball so keller
has a one two three first
with two strikeouts today's starting
pitch for the tigers is spencer turnbull
11th highest walks for nine bases loaded
one out
and ryan takes ball four so the royals
take a one-nothing lead on a bases
loaded walk
so here's alex with the bases loaded two
down the 1-0
to left field on the move and a nice
play by kristen stewart
a little bit of damage could have been a
lot worse spencer turnbull gets out of
it
cordero remains anchored at third and
now it's up to
monday
and he does into the right field corner
and monday will be on his way to third
adelberto montecide has a single and now
an
rbi triple in the first two innings and
the royals lead two nothing here's isak
paredes ooh look at that play
out at second lopez the first double
play
oh yes franco go ahead young man
that was really a nifty footwork
and glove work now cabrera the batter
he struck out swinging his first time up
and this time he got him with a breaking
ball so
keller has struck out miguel cabrera
twice one on one out another lefty at
the plate nick lopez the 2-2
swung on and missed punch out number
four on the night for spencer turnbull
he loves to get hitters to chase up top
mirror field batting for the third time
in the fourth inning two-nothing royals
man on first two outs
three two to mirrorfield swung on and
missed
doesn't strike out very often but
turnbull's punched him out and back to
back at bats
royals expect haas to pull it they have
three infielders on the left side
called third strike that was a perfect
pitch
there's that breaker that nice slider on
the outer half that's on the black man
that's on the black part of the plate
that's the outside part
it's down sally made it look good in us
you got to go
in the red hot at alberto monteci two
for two tonight a bunch single
a stolen base then an rbi triple already
tonight two for two
oh and he has another base hit and he's
going to turn this into a double
and he could have gotten in there
standing if he wanted to and he is a
home run shy of hitting for the cycle
and we're only in the fifth inning oh
that's exciting
seven for his last seven oh man
first and second in a ground ball double
play now you have a runner at third with
two down
and franco lifts it into right center
field
reyes is back and he'll make the play
both runners tag
and salvi moves up to second base and he
got there before monday crossed home
plate
wow you know the way the royals are
playing with this type of
energy they're playing good ball
baseball but really castro betting
exactly and brad keller
gives miguel cabrera the hat trick
daniel norris
is in for spencer turnbull he's working
against the royals here in the sixth
good pitch by daniel good start starts
it off with the strikeout
for alex gordon cordero goes down
swinging
haas had to find it for a moment and
then they make the out at first
the infielders come in and try and keep
minute he's got it good slider tonight
daniel norris strikes out the side here
in the six
here's danny duffy puts runners at
second and third nobody out here in the
seventh
the 2-0 on the ground is short monday
concedes the run
and gets the out at first tigers are on
the board
it's now 3-1 and now the batter will be
eric haas and he'll be facing
scott barlow now the 3-2
fly ball shallow center cordero
lines it up good room tagging the throw
home and
perez dropped it so perez had to try and
make the quick swipe tag
nico slides around excellent tigers now
trailed by a run dazz cameron
monteci flat footed throws on a hop and
he gets cameron
[Applause]
my that
was special and cameron is not
a slow runner and cameron is safe so
it's an infield base hit
his second in-field hit tonight victor
reyes
on the ground to franco out at second
and a double play
that's the second double play for the
royals tonight
eric haas with a runner at first two
down
and a strikeout for han two in the
inning to get his second save of the
year
and the royals have hung on into a pair
of one-run victories over the tigers in
this
final series of the year